is it possible to for sure know that our
universe does not at the fundamental
level have randomness is it possible to
conclusively say
there's no randomness at the bottom
well it's an interesting question i mean
you know
science natural science is an inductive
business right you observe a bunch of
things and you say can we fit these
together what is our hypothesis for
what's going on the thing that i think i
can say fairly definitively is at this
point we understand enough about
fundamental physics
that there is if there was sort of an
extra dice being thrown
it's something that doesn't need to be
there we can get what we see without
that
now
you know could you add that in as an
extra little featuroid
um you know without breaking the
universe uh probably but in fact almost
certainly yes but is it necessary for
understanding the universe no and i
think actually from a a more fundamental
point of view it's
it's i think i might be able to argue so
so one of the things that i've been
interested in have been pretty surprised
that i've had anything sentient to say
about is the question of why does the
universe exist
i didn't think that was a question that
i would you know i thought that was a
far out there metaphysical kind of
thing
uh even the philosophers have stayed
away from that question for the most
part it's so such a kind of uh you know
difficult to address question but i
actually think to my great surprise that
from our physics project and so on that
it is possible to actually
address that question and explain why
the universe exists and i kind of have a
suspicion i've not thought it through i
kind of have a suspicion that that
explanation will eventually show you
that
in no meaningful sense can there be
randomness underneath the universe that
is that if there is
it's something that is necessarily
irrelevant to our perception of the
universe that is that it could be there
but it doesn't matter because in a sense
we've already you know whatever it would
do whatever extra thing it would add is
not relevant to our perception of what's
going on so why
does the universe exist how does uh the
irrelevance of randomness connect to uh
the big why question of silver so okay
so i mean why does the universe exist
well let's see and uh is this the only
universe we got it's the only one
that about that i'm pretty sure so now
you may be which one
which of these topics is better to enter
first why does the universe exist and uh
why you think it's the only one that
exists well i think they're very closely
related okay okay
so i mean the first thing
let's see i mean this why does the
universe exist question
is built on top of all these things that
we've been figuring out about
fundamental physics
because if you want to know why the
universe exists you kind of have to know
what the universe is made of and uh i
think the um well let me let me uh
describe a little bit about
the why does the universe exist question
so the main issue is let's say you have
a model for the universe
and you say i've got this this program
or something and you run it and you make
the universe
now you say well how do you actually why
is that program actually running and
people say you've got this program that
makes the universe what computer is it
running on
right what what does it mean what
actualizes something you know two plus
two equals four but that's different
from saying there's two a pile of two
rocks and another pile of two rocks and
someone moves them together and makes
four so to speak and so what is it that
kind of turns it from being just this
formal thing to being something that is
actualized okay so there we have to
start thinking about well well what do
we actually know about what's going on
in the universe well we are observers of
this universe
but confusingly enough we're part of
so in a sense we what what what if we
say what do we what do we know about
what's going on in the universe well
what we know is what sort of our
consciousness records about what's going
on in the universe
and so consciousness is part of the
fabric of the universe so we're in it
yes we're in it
you